اكملت امانه منطقه حائل في شمال السعوديه
مشروع التطوير المنطقه المجاوره لقلعه
عرفه التاريخيه التي يعود عمرها الى ما
يزيد وعلى 200 عاما المشروع المعلن عنه
يحتوي على 10,000 متر مربع من المسطحات
الخضراء في محيط القلعه التاريخيه
بالاضافه الى ما يزيد على 500 شجره
باختلاف انواعها فضلا عن ممرات للمشاه يصل
طولها الى 900 متر كما يضم المشروع 12 من
فدا للبيع
حياك الله السالم عرفنا اكثر على هذه
القناه
اهلا خالد مساء الخير لك وللمشاهدين
الكرام نعم نقف الان في في المنطقه
المحيطه بقلعه عائله تحديدا في هذا
المشروع بالبدايه خالد دعنا نتعرف عن
القيمه التاريخيه لهذه القلعه التي بنيت
قبل ما يقارب 250 عام على اعلى احد الجبال
في وسط منطقه حائل بنيت كقلعه عسكريه
لتشرف على كافه المناطق المحيطه بمدينه
حائل بعد ذلك مع مرور الزمن تحديدا في
الزمن الحالي اصبحت احد المواقع واحد اهم
المواقع التاريخيه والسياحيه في المنطقه
هي مفتوحه بشكل يوميا للزوار وتشرف عليها
الهيئه العامه
للتراث هذا في ما يخص القلعه اما عن مشروع
تطوير المنطقه المحيطه بقلعه عارف الذي
شارف على النهايه ومن المتوقع ان يتم
تدشينه همم قريبا هذا المشروع عملت عليه
وزاره الشؤون البلديه والقرويه منذ عده
سنوات بدايه من نزع ملكيات المناطق حيطه
بهذه القلعه كانت هناك بعض الاملاك الخاصه
في المناطق المحيطه لان هذا المشروع هو من
جميع الاتجاهات حول القلعه تم نزع ما
يقارب 21 عقارا بقيمه 60 مليون ريال بعد
ذلك بدا العمل الميداني على تطوير هذه
المنطقه كما نشاهد الموقع يحتضن مجموعه من
الساحات العامه والمماشي يحتضن 10,000 متر
مربع من المسطحات الخضراء بالاضافه الى 40
موقع ل- همم الجلوس و12 منفذ للبيع سيتم
تسليمه للمستثمرين لتوفير الخدمات
الاساسيه خالد الموقع يحتضر 900 متر من
مواقع المخصصه للمشي اذا ما تحدثنا عن
المواقع المخصصه للمشي فان حائل هي احوج
من غيرها في هذا الموضوع لعده اسباب
ابرزها الاحصاء الاحصائيات التي تنشرها
العامه للاحصاء اظهرت ان نسبه مما المشي
في منطقه حائل سواء في عام 2019 او حتى في
همم العام الماضي عام 2021 كانت هائل هي
اقل المدن السعوديه في ممارسه المشي لذلك
همم من الممكن ان تعزز مثل هذه المواقع
المخصصه للمشاهده سواء في المواقع
المركزيه مثل قلعه عارف وحتى داخل الاحياء
من ممكن ان تعزز السكان او الاهالي على
ممارسه همم المشي همم وتقليل نسب السمنه
حسب نظرته الاحصائيات التي تنشرها وزاره
الصحه فيما يتعلق عن هذا او في هذا
المشروع من المتوقع ان يتم تجهينه بشكل
رسمي بحضور وزير الشؤون البلديه والقرويه
والاسكان خلال الاسابيع القليله همم همم
القادمه هذا محتوي او هذه ابرز محتويات
مشروع تطوير المنطقه المحيطه بقلعه عارف
في منطقه حائل خالد